welcome to this video a 15 minute game
against d been our winter Oh F Layton
before with a win okay let's see we got
a Sicilian I'm going to go for they open
the zillion let's see the night off the
dragon or this one that's actually an
interesting move it's not played often
and has a somewhat dodgy reputation
because of Bishop b5 check I'll play
that but if i'm not mistaken things are
not so easy for wide but yeah the Sun
check um yeah in a way fights for the
light squares because while blacks
normal move would be Bishop d7 after
which i'm glad to exchange the light
squared Bishop and then the d5 square
becomes an even more serious issue
however i'm not mistaken i think 97 is
some it's maybe possible here yes okay
after that I'm going to exchange and
play Knight to f5 this check is also in
a way the explanation for for a six in
the night off a six and the night off
sort of capacity five as it controls be
the b5 square okay g6 young okay I'm
going back to you three because d5 is
the spot for the Knights here anyway
ok 95 to come
yeah i wonder if i should i can do that
night e to d5 and then maybe Bishop to
g5 next could be an idea there's also
always this funny idea if he goes Bishop
g7 now to play Bishop to h6 using this
Knight f6 fork but Bishop g7 Bishop
Bishop h6 you can just castle and then
Bishop h6 is not really helping me in
any way it's just the kind of flashy
move showing look I can do that but it's
not not really leading to do anything
great what I'm trying to do here with
Bishop g5 is if he should castle now
okay actually in case of castling I have
too tempting options a purely
strategical 1 and 0 he's actually almost
forcing me to do it what I was getting
at is this is taking twice on his seven
and then planting a knight on d5 which
would be the typical case of the eternal
night never to be kicked away from d5 on
the other hand here i also have Knight
f6 check which is quite a good move
Knight f6 Bishop f6 Bishop f6 and the
rook is hanging mmm yeah that's sort not
so good but I don't want I want to I
want it very simple here just just doing
this
so that at the engine I will have the
knight on d5 and there is absolutely
nothing black and do to to chase it away
I could have gone there immediately but
it's there is no way to prevent it um
wonder wonder what's the best possible
set up around the night hmm yeah I guess
on a plane is first the only counterplay
of any sorts that black hairs is some
with f5 and wondering what the best
possible setup is night I'm not in
retrospect I'm not even sure if 95 or so
great adults it blocks the default where
I could start to increase pressure with
heavy pieces but it's a certainly fine
for me if he goes f5 there is no threat
really i can i will probably play a free
just to get some additional support c3
is just meant to to cover the sea porn
now a force fairly fairly typical i
would like to play a queen to be five
trying to provoke a queen trade and a
black can never take on be 58 x b5 would
open up them I'm the a file for my plane
yeah I will play a three just just to
give a bit more support if he takes on
e4 now that's actually not clear what
I'm doing I can also take with the Queen
both captures make some sense Queen
takes was my original intention but yeah
of course f take CF take C is also not
bad at all the structure with this
internal knight on d5 is some good for
wide in any kind of endgame and also
trading trading rooks and Queen the so
it's perfectly OK and a minor piece
endgame the night is just so much better
because it's a totally static position
uh-huh that's going back to da and
interesting maybe coming to g5 or age
form ok I I'll take this chance to to
open up the Queen side hmm this was a
bit miss time maybe now that I think of
it ok Queen a success was the original
idea but I'm not sure that this was I
thought after a five he maybe could have
taken first only form but I can I can
take with the pawn rook takes and Queen
takes everyone yeah that's it that's
true in fact ya hear an additional
problem for blankets that I'm
threatening Queen take CA to winning the
exchange
yeah the question is should I even
should I even grab it or isn't what is
this maybe not even the best way to play
Queen c8 quidsi 897 check King 2h7
probably night c8 rook c8 and then takes
on your phone yeah that's in fact very
good as I'm threatening rook f7
immediately so I can I can take that but
the difficulty is a bit this position to
determine the best the best way possible
as there are many many good ones and if
you manage to play the the best move
ready like two or three times it's
likely to be the end of the game and it
probably eases the the task then you
have a head of you who is not even
taking mmm yeah well there is no threat
whatsoever i can check just give the
check here and now take on your form so
yeah black does not even have a check on
or any meaningful counterplay scat Queen
III maybe but i want to i use this light
now here to try to finish this quickly
night x 36 being one threat check yeah i
can take 96 or maybe I'm have seven now
that's not that's maybe the easiest a
queen trader with the rook down it's not
always going for that check okay ya
black ass look down in an endgame that's
really a bit much
I am threatening night f5 now so III
night and five is just down just for a
moment night f-5e to look g7 King age
eight look at you one looked it too hmm
but this Ruby seven okay always some
some caution needed when you are
battling chat a fired one spawn that's
always tricky and the background is also
weak but I have more than one way to
deal with that rookie to for example now
I can go look it seven and take you to
our advanced with the king this is
probably the easier way
black resides yeah this was a very
typical middle game where white got the
mentioned eternal night um yeah in this
position here I think that 97's not so
clear I had looked at this line ages ago
I mean it has a very bad reputation but
I think I looked at this years ago and
thought that this isn't so terrible
really yeah okay he went Bishop d7 after
which Jan took and tonight to f5 yeah
and he had the most interesting way to
play as not g6 but Knight f6 the idea is
if I now play them normal looking nice
night before that black has Knight takes
e4 that's quite funny but not bad at all
there are there are created lines like
night g7 Bishop g7 94 d5 Bishop h6
that's very weird there is a very
similar position in the carers attack
off the square vanagon but there is g4
plate in addition that's quite funky
yeah but like him just castle and it's
not clear that this accomplishes much
instead of Knight c3 and whites will
probably play something else um 11 way
could be just to go f3 here d5 and
Bishop g5 for example could be an
interesting way to play yeah g6 is not
really helping because what you don't
want the bishop on g7 really because
it's not doing much damn
you know and T is mentioned here there's
this fleshy move Bishop h6 this however
does not lead to anything just quite
equal yeah Bishop g5 was I think you
know just ok and now aged six here it's
interesting i went for the totally
strategic continuation but yeah 90 of
six also was interesting this is not
exactly bad yeah like castles and then
something maybe f4 is a computer
suggestion yeah i went for the for the
strategical method which establishes
this as mentioned eternal night on 95
and here white will play em mostly em on
the queenside and along the d file this
is fairly typical initial setup and b6
is of course very helpful because i'd
like to have some sort of point that i
can attack on the queenside if he
wouldn't have played b6 i still would
have played a4 a5 rook a3 b3 this kind
of maneuvers but will be six it was
pretty clear that there is some this a 5
attack i went here and t i played a 5
i'm not sure that this is a timed so
well not really I have all the time in
the world maybe I should have been a bit
more cautious this I'm not really sure
about you took and Queen 86 and I'm not
not totally sold on this rook be eight
for example is a good news yeah it's not
clear that this is so great really I
played a five a bit too quickly between
hours
is a problem you can oops rather take it
here and then mmm route 87 that's a
capture on your form yeah this is
probably just okay for black so this was
mistimed but okay this just blundered
Quincy aid and okay well this it's not
helping much this is not a thought like
you want eggs and now take him yeah now
white is threatening to enter here like
has no way really to to hold this it's
just the a pawn this week and this is a
dead piece of white will win this quite
easily in any case yeah it's um this is
not totally totally bad this move but
there is some some reason why why the
night of you with a six is covering b5
there is there are multiple reasons for
that but this is one reason in fact II
five is very comparable to what we had
on the board and this is sort of the
Gotham yeah one of the the predecessors
of the night off in a way is six was a
night off or let's say don't think night
off really invented it but this was the
kind of invention that prepared a five
so there is some some point to it but if
I've it's it's not as bad as it looked
in in this game alright thanks for
watching